Now, in addition to recording
feedback on what to improve, we've
been recording feedback on what parts
of our app really resonate with users.
This feedback is really vital to share
in a presentation on your prototype.
It will be one of your greatest assets.
Nothing shows that your concept
resonates with users quite like
hearing or seeing one of them be
excited when using your prototype.
Because of this,
it can be a good idea to get video or
audio recordings of your
user testing sessions.
The one rule is to always,
always, always get permission
from your subjects first.
We've said it before, and
its really vital that you do this.
Ask before you record and
ask every user.
What you need is a media release
form that covers research use and
presentation use.
This is a thing you should look for
online and then customize and
run by a lawyer before you use it.
Over the course of a few
iterations of user testing,
you should be able to find some users
who absolutely adore your design.
If not, you may need to iterate more
before you're ready to demo your app.